I'm a rapper right you didn't know that
you did no you'd be forgiven for not
knowing it but I I am a rapper I do
freestyle rap that means rap that you
make up it's not written or prepared
it's improvised in the moment will only
be seen Now by you guys and never be
repeated again what would you like to
hear a rap about
getting hit by a bus thank you so much
yeah has that ever happened to you in
your life
I can't see are you in a wheelchair I
can't see like no
oh
being hit by a bus okay great I love it
great um people over here front to the
back but this wedge here which all rap
about Hungarian princess there were two
so you said Bulgarian princess is that
true and then behind you coked up
Canadian ski jump a coked up Canadian
ski jumper yeah
great a coked up Canadian ski jumper and
a Bulgarian princess being hit by a bus
so far these are great suggestions okay
we're gonna have to because there's only
two more suggestions left we're gonna
have to kind of make it more it's all
kind of this front section and this side
section what's the next suggestion gonna
be
okay so there were three
but you wait you waited the longest sir
and so what happened was the person said
monkey surgeon on vacation and we were
all like is it a surgeon who operates on
monkeys or is the monkey a surgeon
someone said bestiality we were like do
people [ __ ] the monkey who's a surgeon
and then you came through just waiting
with Iraq war and everyone loved that
everyone loved it so that's pretty fun
and then people in this section but at
the back what do you want to rap out
okay
there were two so did you did you say
did you say it was it was Kanye and then
you said sketches so was it Kanye
working with Skechers okay cool because
Adidas have dropped him because he's
he's an anti-semite uh and then you said
Jerry Sandusky which and then everyone
laughed which makes me think that's a
bad person okay
um would someone would someone be
willing to tell me who Jerry Sandusky is
from the front row why do we look
he was a coach at Penn State who raped
children what a fun rap topic what a
really fun
the problem is like Kanye has been
coming up a lot recently people are
always like rap about that and I'm I'm
kind of sick about giving it air time so
Jerry Sandusky is
so these are the topics right a coked up
Canadian ski jumper getting hit by a bus
a Bulgarian princess Jerry Sandusky
who's a coach at Penn State who raped
children
um
re-actual children or teenagers
teenagers okay because there's a there's
a difference between
pedophilia and ephibophilia no like a
syntactical difference the Greeks will
uh pedophile is someone who fancies
children and a FIBA file is someone who
fancies post pubescent children so I
studied Greek right they [ __ ] a lot of
kids and they wanted you to know people
like people like you [ __ ] kids dude
they'll be like yeah I'm a pedophile
right if you said that they you know the
Greeks were very in the past not modern
day Greeks I'm not saying
I'm not saying that okay
I love masaka don't you know
and then the the final one was the Iraq
War okay
tell you what um band can we make it um
can we make it like kind of more chill
and that doesn't mean slow but more like
I don't know if it's like Soulful or
laid back because I feel like going in
super aggro on the whole child [ __ ]
bit will be really upsetting but if we
like make it a bit cooler and smoother
people will be like yeah you know it's
distasteful but it Bops it's it's
it's a strategy very much pursued by R
Kelly I think it really works it really
you can kind of you know
my dream is to have the Jamaican lady
going that's what I want
that's what I
um that's my dream if this rap ends with
you just go
okay
okay
I've got to prove myself making sure you
trust me starting with something else
but moved to Sandusky a lady who's busty
where she's coming from I'll share with
you oh hello a lady from Bulgaria I'm
walking in yes I impress large breasts
large diamonds you know that I'm a
princess I say wow 10 out of 10 complete
even though you sound like The Count
from Sesame Street it's kind of
confusing maybe you could wed me bring
the houses to get the royalty messy me
and you I go on holiday she shows up got
an instructor Canadian he's coped up he
says we're gonna learn the ski jumping
apres ski wood Chalet me and her pumpkin
humping loving it but this fellow
Canadian guy who loves snow and blow
well technically that's a different type
of snow no mistake take the cocaine in
the large line he snakes he's left or
right like a Slalom ski you know I see
but he's moving so high like the veritas
girl that's the bird that symbolized the
nation went back to Iraq twice that's
infatuation the first one George boss
senior then the sun was like hey I might
be teenier but I'm going in I'm gonna
get Saddam Hussein even though we put
him in power in the first place it's
ironic you really wanted it I won't
spoil saying there's nuclear warheads
now just oil your lies like psych we
were making up reports going gets the
damn hang him when he was caught head
separated from his body capital
punishment they did the shoddy but I'll
do it properly I'm a monkey surgeon I've
got an urgent to walk in here yeah refix
it I served them a real person a man not
the ape I make sure that their tendons
get fixed no mistake and while I'm there
an urge grabs me the surgeon of the
monkey wants to practice bestiality and
all the other nurses and anisitis say
that's illegal surgeon we'll see to this
release from this yeah I'm moving on
went to Penn State oh I feel I'm proven
on someone already screams like please
no don't say many raps about Jerry Sando
that's what I call him like we're wrong
the first name turns he picked out his
favorite ones of all the first term at
the leads he gets them on the bench he
says I want to get you in a kind of
clench in a passionate lock look when
push comes to shove surely it's improper
but maybe he's in love maybe he was a
groomer I assume but okay he steps out
of the conference room and says I'm
going to escape no one will know he
walks right down the street that Jerry
fellow people say Jerry you're a
horrible person in front of us and
what's the Justice served he gets hit by
a [ __ ] butt
foreign